it is great to welcome back to the
program today dr. Aubrey de Grey who is
the chief science officer of Sens
Research Foundation which is a
biomedical research charity based in
California developing new therapies to
combat aging we've talked to him over
the years a number of times great to
have you back Ari good to be back for
people who I'm increasingly following
the space that you work in there are all
sorts of subreddits about longevity and
curing aging and using similar language
to language that i at least first heard
from you when I saw your 60 minutes
appearance at this point who knows how
many years ago it was so in some sense
the movement is getting more traction in
the terms that you've sort of defined
for it but has there been progress in
the goal of curing aging there's been
enormous progress yes it was 2006 I was
on 60 minutes so it's been a long long
time but yeah I mean the reason why
there is progress in the conversation in
the language that's being used is simply
because there has been progress in the
laboratory and even in the clinic and
the you know that it's really nice and
day how different things have become
even in the last three or four years
essentially the science has been you
know floating along slowly but surely
and you know every publication that
comes out it's just one small step
towards a you know towards a real
comprehensive solution and therefore it
one small step in terms of the
credibility of the idea and really you
know things started taking off the work
that we do at cents Research Foundation
has in many cases moved out into the
private sector in the sense that we've
been able to spin out projects as
startup companies which have been able
to attract good investment that's really
important of course because I've always
said the you know the the level of
financial support for this work is the
rate limited there is no question we
could be going fast there and there are
lots of people out there where deep
pockets who are willing to be
comfortable with high-risk high-reward
investments even
they're very uncomfortable with
high-level philanthropy so that means
that these projects that have been spun
out and now being funded at her level
which honestly I think suffice is you
know the words it makes the rate limited
be the actual cements rather than the
money and of course that's just that's
the first step you know such things move
on they go into clinical trials we get
even more excitement and even and it
becomes easier to get money so now that
sense Research Foundation we still have
a bunch of projects we're not yet at the
position of being able to kind of
declare victory and say that other
people can do everything but we have
definitely been able to slim down narrow
the range of areas which we feel are
still being neglected by other people
and therefore focus more intensively on
them so you've previously said that you
believe the first human that will live
to a thousand has already been born and
there will be a lot of people who might
think you know over the last ten years
that David's been talking to Aubree I
don't know that we're really closer to
that
okay can you talk about some of the
specific advancements you believe there
have been in the last ten years
sure absolutely well so first of all
let's remember how I achieved that
conclusion that music the first place
first of all we have to remember that
the idea that people alive today could
live to a thousand does not equate to
the idea that within the next couple of
decades we will develop therapies that
completely eliminate aging which is what
would be required to actually give us a
life expectancy in four digits sure what
it means instead is that we will develop
therapies which give maybe only a few
decades of additional life but they give
that additional life to people who are
already in middle age at the time which
means that we rejuvenate those people
and by ourselves the scientists time to
make the therapies a bit better and give
the same people you know version 2.0 of
the therapies a few decades later that
give them a few more decades of the
or healthy life and so on so basically
it's all about keeping one step ahead of
the problem and it's very clear that
once we get even a couple of decades of
additional life the people who are
already in middle-age buy a genuine
rejuvenation therapies that it will
become progressively easier to stay one
step ahead of the problem so that's how
I come to the conclusion that we could
basically forget about aging once we've
got those couple of decades and then the
question is are we closer to getting
those first couple of decades and the
answer is absolutely the things that we
can really point to the show that we're
getting closer of course different
depending on how deep you want to get
into the science but even at the level
of you know headlines in the newspapers
we are seeing very clear progress
perhaps the most conspicuous example is
unity biotechnology which is a company
explicitly working on rejuvenation on
eliminating a particular type of damage
namely senescence cells and they've
already got into clinical trial of less
than a year ago I guess it was um but
they've also been able to attract very
very large amounts of investment they
were able to bring in more than 300
million dollars about two years ago now
and that was before they'd even begun
that first clinical trial you know
that's the kind of money that biotech
companies normally bring in when they're
already in Phase three so that really
gives you a sense of the magnitude of
the buzz around all of this in the
investment sector and of course the
reason they're getting this money is
because they're getting good results in
lab and incidentally they still are the
first clinical trial came back really
really promising um so that's just one
example but the reason why we were able
to spin out so many startups so many
projects into startup companies which
are not doing that was unity but they're
doing well is simply the same things
that work in the laboratories of the
academics that we've been working with
all this time and of course in our own
labs as well has actually given
sufficiently concrete actual results
that have been able to be published in
high-profile journals and so on that the
ambassadors have started to feel that
the time is right
so you know he wanted an example let's
take yeah let's take arteriosclerosis
the stiffening of the arteries that's
caused mostly by a chemical process
called glycation and the chemical and
molecular nature of it has been
understood for a long time but actually
repairing that chemical change in the
arteries is something that people had
totally given up on and we funded a
group at Yale University for a number of
years to actually work properly on this
and they had great success we had a
first breakthrough that got published in
science magazine the most prestigious
scientific publication in the world and
that work then proceeded with the
development of enzymes that can indeed
restore the elasticity of the arteries
by essentially reversing this chemical
change and that was sufficiently
impressive that we've now spun that out
into a company that's in the process of
getting financed we've done the same
thing with atherosclerosis we've done
the same thing with macular degeneration
you know so this is happening time and
time again and if people want to sort of
think about the different categories of
technologies or treatments that might
someday be available do you have a
strong feeling about whether the future
of this field is in medications that are
taken the way medications are taken
today nanotechnology that can do repair
at the cellular cellular level is
another idea focusing on curing diseases
that are more the diseases that one gets
when they live longer rather than the
sort of contagious disease that often
significantly limits life expectancy is
there a one area that you think is the
area of prior priority here well that's
more to do with the mode of delivery and
I believe that these two circles are
going to be delivered it's probably
going to be rather similar to what we
see today most of it will be by
injections because we'll be putting
things into the bloodstream so you know
just in the same way that we vaccinate
today so
will actually be immunotherapy you know
stimulating the immune system to do
things that it doesn't naturally do well
enough but a lot of it will be stem cell
therapies and gene therapies so
injecting engineered DNA in in
engineered viruses of some kind you know
so from the point of view of the
recipient the patient it'll look pretty
normal one thing we've always got to
remember though is that we're not
talking about curing anything we're
talking you know the word cure has too
much baggage around it so I have to be
very careful with this when you cure an
infectious disease that means you remove
it from the body so that the person
doesn't actually suffer from that
disease you know unless they get
reinfected
whereas aging is a side effect of being
alive in the first place and we don't
want to cure being alive in the first
place so what we need to do instead is
clean up the side effects the damage
that the body does to itself in the
course of its normal operation cleaning
that up periodically so that it never
reaches a level of abundance a level of
contamination if you like that exceeds
what the body can tolerate yes so that's
actually I mean there's this idea that
that is often repeated which is that at
a physical level the body seems to sort
of top out even potentially at living a
hundred and ten or a hundred and twenty
years it's that something that you a
accept and believe that that's what it
is that you are working to change or or
actually reject it and have a different
thought altogether about that it's what
we try to change you know when people
say there's a natural limit to how long
people can live clearly what they're
actually saying is conditional on the
availability of the medicines that exist
today they can't we can't say anything
about what medicines of the future might
do to transcend that so-called natural
limit the whole point of medicine just
like any other technology is to change
this it's the way that the world is so
that it doesn't behave the way naturally
does but rather we manipulate it so um
yes absolutely that limit is you know
the great deal of noise made about that
limit and I honestly feel that that's a
bit of a problem that people kind of
it's part of this what I call the Pro
aging trance when
somebody doesn't study even a really
poor study that his conclusion is that
it's that we can't get beyond 115 or 120
or whatever it'll get published in
really high-profile journals as if as if
it were actually important well and when
in fact it's really just hype right so
of course yes that's exactly what we're
trying to change we're trying to keep
people healthy for a longer period than
they would naturally be healthy for and
that will have the side effect of
keeping them alive longer on average
what is your thought about life
expectancy recently being down a bit in
the United States I mean is that even
are you working in a completely
different way where these year-to-year
shifts don't don't really have any
bearing on the type of work that you're
doing or is that something of concern
it's completely different
yeah I mean it you know of course it's
concern in another sense you know I
don't like the fact that life expectancy
is stagnating but of course we know a
large part of why that is you know it's
a lot of its to do with lifestyle and
sure that's nothing to do with what
we're doing what we're working on of
course it may have an impact I mean what
we're working on may have an impact on
the limits to longevity that are created
by lifestyle in the sense that once we
get really good at repairing the various
types of damage that the body does to
itself then you know it won't really
matter if you have a lifestyle that
slightly accelerates the rate at which
the body is creating that damage in the
first place it just means that you'll
have to you know apply these therapies a
little bit more thoroughly and a little
bit more frequently than if you have if
you were living the way your mother told
you to do you have either a diet
exercise or lifestyle regimen that is in
any way informed by the the research
that you are involved in and follow
closely no I don't that's not because I
think that such things are a bad idea
it's because number one I happen to be
very well built
I'm just really you know lucky guy in
terms of my Constitution and whenever I
get my biological age measured in any
way
I always come up way younger than my
actual age so for me that's kind of an
if it if it ain't broke don't fix it
logic yeah people may not know but
you're actually a hundred and five the
other thing is that of course you know I
spend my life running around the world
that's one thing I do it's definitely
bad for my longevity which they don't
get nearly enough sleep but you know I
figure I'm hastening the defeat of aging
by a larger amounts than the amount that
I'm shortening my life so I think it's
okay
I'm just being flippant of course yeah I
mean so no but the thing about lifestyle
and diets for other people is we know
that there are some people out there who
have you know drawn a short straw or two
genetically or whatever
for example people like Ray Kurzweil who
come down with type 2 diabetes in their
30s right people like that we probably
can substantially normalize their rate
of aging through the kinds of medicines
and supplements that exist today so
that's great but for people who are
already doing Aborigine well especially
people like me who are doing really well
we know I think we can say very
confidently that there's nothing that
anybody can do that will give more than
a couple of years of additional healthy
life now a couple of years it's better
than nothing so I'm certainly not
objecting to that but also we have to
remember that the the things that a
person should do are different from one
person to the next some particular diet
or supplement may be important for one
person and so for another because it was
minor really really nuanced differences
in their in their genetics or whatever
and it's really hard to find that out
except just by experimentation so when I
say when people ask me you know what
should i do should I do an Atkins diet
or a paleo diet or whatever I say I have
no idea I say what you need to do is pay
attention to your own body and do what
works no question about that yeah in a
lot of fields even in medicine going
increasingly in that direction of really
customized treatments even for the
conditions that we do start to have more
of a grasp of how to treat
been speaking with dr. Aubrey de Grey
the chief science officer at Sens
Research Foundation
Aubrey so great to talk to you as always
thank you